Wir blicken auf den europäischen Fußball bei den Männern. Das heißt heute ein bisschen Champions League und ein bisschen La Liga, ein bisschen Serie A. Das ist das Menü einer etwas anderen Ligatur. Schön, dass ihr mit dabei seid. Schön, dass Mario Rieker und Nils Kern mit dabei sind. Jetzt geht's los.
Und nun im Programm der Rasenfunk.
Der Blick auf andere Ligen.
Ich hab Bock. Wie sieht's bei dir aus, Nils? Schön, dass du da bist. Guten Morgen.
Ja, Buenos Dias. Hier ist ja fast so viel los wie im Parkhaus oder in der U-Bahn nach einem Heimspiel des FC Bayern.
Aber absolut. Und ich bin natürlich auch sehr froh, dass hier in der Ligatur der Meistertitel im Derby Milano gecalled wurde. Und das muss ja auch wirklich ganz fantastisch gewesen sein. Ich hatte mit Frauenbundesliga zu tun, deswegen konnte ich es leider nicht live sehen. Aber ich will nicht verhehlen, während ich die Sendung dann fertig gemacht habe irgendwann Nacht, vielleicht lief da noch mal das Spiel im Real Life auf einem zweiten Bildschirm. Und vielleicht habe ich zwischendurch auch mal nicht Shownotes gemacht, sondern da nur hingeguckt. Das war schon, ja, das ist irgendwie schön, wenn solche Spiele dann auch halten, was man sich von ihnen verspricht. Das war schon was Besonderes. Nils, dein Anzang Hero bitte. Entschuldigung, ne, MVP, wir sind ja beim MVP. Meine Güte, was ist denn mit mir los?
Ich kann doch erst den MVP machen, machen wir alles der Ordnung.
Ich habe mich an die Reihenfolge gehalten, die du mir geschickt hast, ohne nachzudenken. Alles gut, MVP bitte.
Dann war es auch mein Fehler, ja. Ich muss jetzt eine Doppelerwähnung, oder den hatte ich eben schon kurz erwähnt, aber ich finde, Alexander Sirloot ist aktuell der Spieler, der so mit am meisten überperformt oder am meisten aus seinen Chancen rausholt. Ich glaube nur, Jude Bellingham hat noch einen höheren XG in der Liga mit plus sechs, aber Sirloot hat auch irgendwie fünf Tore mehr als erwartet. Der hat schon zwei richtig gute Jahre bei Real Sociedad hinter sich und hat jetzt diese Torbeteiligungsanzahl, 25 Stück, jetzt auch schon fast mit Villarreal in seiner Debüt-Saison ausgeglichen. Also ist da auch ein sehr, sehr wichtiger Spieler gemeinsam mit Gérard Moreno da, Doppelsturm und das obwohl jetzt Sirloot gar nicht die 11 Meter schießen darf, das ist Chefsache Moreno. Dani Parejo also spielt da eine Top-Saison, hat aus den letzten acht Spieltagen auch acht Tore rausgeholt und ist da eben, wie gesagt, so ein bisschen aktuell die Lebensversicherung. Nicht nur, dass er überperformt, sondern einfach auch da ein absoluter Fixpunkt im Angriff ist. So ein 1, 90 Meter Mann gibt es jetzt auch nicht so auf einer Liga, das wird dann schon auch ganz gut genutzt und eben all diese guten Zahlen, ohne dass er jetzt der klare Standardschütze ist, finde ich schon beeindruckend und dadurch, dass man ihn ja ein bisschen noch aus der Bundesliga erkennt, finde ich ihn da sehr erwähnenswert.
17 Treffer hat er jetzt eben in seinen bisherigen 25 Spielen und durfte damit ja auch in der Torjägerliste relativ weit vorne sein. Rang 3 hinter Artem Dovbek. Ach ja, den haben wir hier auch schon häufiger erwähnt von Girona und einem gewissen Jude Bellingham. Also das läuft wirklich sehr gut. Stimmt, genau, sie teilen sich ja. Meine Güte, heute lassen mich alle Webseiten im Stich. Warum wird denn das hier als Platz 3 ausgewiesen? Nee, die Seite war es nicht. Aber gut, also mein Unsung Hero ist nicht meine persönliche Vorbereitung auf diese Sendung hier. Nils, mach doch dann gleich mit deinem Unsung Hero weiter, wenn ich das eh schon angekündigt habe.
Unsung ist so der Begriff, aber ganz so unbesungen ist er gar nicht speziell. Türkische Fans schreien seinen Namen gerne raus. Es ist der lachende Name, es ist Ada Güler. Der hätte auch der Moment des Spieltags sein können, denn er hat jetzt in seinem La Liga-Debüt direkt mal auch getroffen. Das war der 1-0-Sieg gegen Real Sociedad von Real Madrid. Schöne Kombination. Chur Meni raus auf Coverhalt, er direkt in den Strafraum und an eine Sküle. Er läuft ein. Das war natürlich pures Talent und Wille. Nein, das war ja Stadion-Tag.
Mentalität was bitte.
Mentalität natürlich. Er zeigt mittlerweile, dass er das Talent absolut hat, wie sich die Mannschaft für ihn gefreut hat, weil alle wissen, er hat es eigentlich so drauf. Und im Training geht jeder Schuss in den Winkel. Aber er kann es halt noch nicht so zeigen, weil Carlo Ancelotti ihn nicht so einsetzt. Wir reden da über 166 Pflichtspielminuten, jetzt schon zwei Treffer. Dazu kommt noch ein herausgeholter Elfmeter, zwei Aluminium-Treffer. Also so lesen sich die Statistiken schon ganz gut. Und es war einfach ein schöner Moment, dass da, wie sich die Mannschaft mit ihm gefreut hat, dass auch der, er jetzt Güller, mal wieder lachen konnte, steht ja sein Name dafür. Deswegen ist er da so ein bisschen unbesungen, vielleicht bei neutralen Fans, aber auch wenn, wie gesagt, türkische Fans den Namen schon ganz gerne in den Mund nehmen.
Aber glaubst du denn, also Güller ist ja eines der größten türkischen Talente, und es war schon interessant, dass er jetzt zu dieser Saison zur Real gewechselt ist. Glaubst du, der wird seine Rolle finden, wenn eben dieses Mittelfeld irgendwann dann doch mal verjüngt werden muss, weil er ist ja schon offensives Mittelfeld, so seine Position?
Ja, und da er jetzt auch speziell im Sommer nicht nur Endricchi aus Brasilien kommen wird, gut, Mittelstürmer, aber dann wahrscheinlich auch dieser eine von PSG, wird schon da die Konkurrenz nicht unbedingt kleiner, aber ich glaube einfach, dass er mit seinen 19 Jahren schon einerseits die Geduld hat und auch weiß, worauf es drauf ankommt bei Real Madrid. Das hat nicht jeder, und trotzdem hat ein Kubo ja seinen Platz gefunden, hat auch ein Martin Oedegaard seinen Platz gefunden, die vielleicht, wie gesagt, ein bisschen wenig Geduld hatten bei Real Madrid, aber dafür Andernorts Geduld. Ich glaube, Ada Güller weiß schon, dass er da die Geduld haben muss, bekommt das auch von seinen Mitspielern eingeredet, eingeträgt hat, will sich auch gar nicht vielleicht verleihen lassen im Sommer. Und er hatte jetzt auch die Hinrunde komplett verletzungsbedingt verpasst, deswegen ist dieser Zug für Real Madrid auch so ein bisschen abgefahren. Aber jetzt dann wird er, glaube ich, den Neustart wagen im Sommer und wie gesagt, er ist ja voll integriert, spricht auch schon Spanisch, hat er viel gelernt. Er sendet schon viele positive Signale, um zu bleiben, um auch von Ancelotti häufiger eingesetzt zu werden, zumindest dann in der kommenden Saison. Aber dadurch, dass jetzt auch die Liga quasi wie laufen ist noch für Spieltage, wird er da jetzt noch mehr zu Einsatzzeiten kommen.
Sehr, sehr spannend. Und dann schauen wir uns noch den Anzang Hero in der Serie A an, Mario.
Ja, ich habe mich mal für einen Ersatztorwart entschieden, der ganz spontan einspringen musste, Marco Sportiello, beim Topspiel Juve gegen Milan. Mike Mignot hat sich beim Aufwärmen verletzt. Und dann, wir waren gerade bei Spielen, die versprechen, was sie halten. Ehrlicherweise war es hier auch so, aber weil ich mir versprochen hatte, dass es ein richtiger Trex-Kick wird. Also Juve unter Max Allegri. Und Milan unter Stefano Pioli. Es ist gerade nicht mehr das, was es mal war. Oder bei Max Allegri ist es genau das, was es immer war. Ja, aber im Endeffekt hatte Juve extrem viele gute Chancen hinten raus noch. Marcos Portiello hat alles gehalten. Sieben Abschlüsse aufs Tor bekommen. Großchancen gehalten. Und hat damit Milan so gut wie sicher die Vizemeisterschaft eingetütet, weil es weiterhin jetzt fünf Punkte vor Juve sind. Und ich glaube, das ist ein kleiner Punkt, mit dem man sich dann vielleicht am Ende doch noch anfreunden kann. Das ist so, wo klar Inter dann beim Derby-Meister wird oder so. Aber ist es ehrlicherweise so viel Auf- und Ab- und Verletzung und was auch immer. Und auch bei Milan hat nicht immer alles funktioniert. Das glaube ich, dann kann man auch Not vorziehen, dass sie dann in der Saison Zweiter werden. Und er hat jetzt dann in dem Spieltag ganz großen Anteil dran gehabt.
Ersatztorhüter, die in eine Rolle spielen, das liest man doch immer wieder gerne und sieht man auch gerne. Und was war dein Moment des Spieltags?
Ja, kann man direkt dann daran anschließen. Also du hattest es schon angesprochen. Natürlich das Derby am Spieltag davor, das die Meisterschaft, die 20. für Inter, bedeutet hat und darauf aufbauend jetzt am letzten Spieltag die Busparade und Mailand, also das war eine Meisterfeier, wie sie sein sollte. Und das lustige, wenn du gesagt hast, du hast auch noch ein bisschen ReLive des Derbys geschaut, da ging es da hinten raus auch nochmal richtig hoch her. Und die Kollegen Dumfries und Tera Hernandez, die mochten sich schon immer sehr, sehr gerne. Und bei der Busparade ist auf einmal so ein Doppelhalter von Fans an Dumfries auf den Bus hochgegeben worden. Und er hat das kurz angeguckt und dann auch voller Imprunst hochgezeigt und da ist Denzel Dumfries, der einen Hund an der Leine führt. Und dieser Hund trägt das Gesicht von Tera Hernandez. Das ist nah an der Kürtellinie dran, finde ich. Das ist vielleicht schon einen Tick drunter. Aber ich finde, das darf einmal erlaubt sein im Jahr. Und was ich jetzt ganz lustig fand, das ist bestimmt KI oder so, die das gemacht hat. Aber ich habe in sozialen Netzwerken kleine Lego-Sets gesehen, wo ein Dummfriesmännchen, das ein Tera Hernandez-Männchen als Hund an der Leine führt. Das hat alles vereint, was sich in der Stadt entladen hat. Und ich finde es aus der Warte auch in Ordnung, weil die Milan und die Interfans ja schon seit Jahren einen Friedenspakt haben. Obwohl die Rivalität so groß ist, wird sich ja sonst zwischen denen vereinigt. Und dann kann man mal beide Augen zudrücken, wenn auch ein leicht desplizierter, destipierlicher, oh Gott. Ihr wisst, was ich meine. Wenn ein Spieler ein Plakat hochhalten würde, wo er sonst wahrscheinlich, da könnte man auch drüber reden, ob er dafür eine Sperre bekommen muss oder bestraft werden muss. Aber man muss, glaube ich, nicht alles immer vor das Sportgericht ziehen. Da sind tatsächlich in Italien in den letzten Jahren schon schlimmere Sachen, die nicht geahndet worden sind, gemacht worden.
Unter anderem deswegen ist es ja nach allem, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere, auch zu diesem Friedenspakt zwischen Milan und Interfans gekommen. Ich weiß gerade gar nicht, wann die Sendung war. Ich suche sie nochmal raus. Ich werde sie in den Shownotes verlinkt haben, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer. Es gab mehrere Fälle von Polizeigewalt und aber auch von Faneskalationen, also beidseitig, und dann die eines gestorbenen Fans. Da habe ich damals noch darüber gesprochen, hier im Rasenfunk, weil damals der Innenminister, der aus der Fanszene kommt, ganz anders reagiert hat, als alle Innenminister, die man sonst so kennt. Grüße auch hier an deutsche Innenminister, die Derbys komplett ohne Gästefans fordern. Klar, alles logisch. Was denn alles eigentlich noch? Die armen Fußballfans. Da haben wir auch darüber gesprochen. Da kam das in einigen Nebensätzen auch durchaus mit vor, dass eben diese besondere Situation der Fans, die ja irrere Depressionen in der Serie A zu erdulden haben, eben auch zum Teil zu solchen Verbrüder und manchmal auch Schwesterungen geführt haben in der Serie A. Ich werde es noch mal verlinken. Und dann fehlt uns noch dein Moment, Nils.
Ja, vom 33. Spieltag, der im Moment das Spiel dazu hatte ich vorhin schon leicht angedeutet. Das war der Kampf um Platz 4. Den hat Atletico mit 3-1 für sich entschieden. Bei diesem Spiel kam es primär zu einer unschönen Situationsszene, aber daraus ist der Moment des Spieltags geboren. Nico Williams wurde vermeintlich rassistisch beleidigt. Zumindest hat er in der ersten Halbzeit irgendwann den Schiedsrichter darauf hingewiesen. Da gab es gerade gewisse Geräusche. Egal, darum geht es jetzt hier nicht. Sondern darum, dass er, ich glaube, 5 Minuten später, selbst den Ausgleich erzielt hat und dann beim Torjubel wieder in diese Ecke gelaufen ist und dabei ganz klar mit dem Finger auf seiner Haut gezeigt hat, um da eben den Atletico-Fans zu zeigen, hey, guck mal, darauf kommt es an. Und von dem her war das eine besondere Szene, auch wenn natürlich kein schöner Hintergrund, wie es dazu kam. Aber da hat er ein gutes Zeichen auf den Platz gegeben. Hat am Ende nicht gereicht, Atletico hat 3-1 gewonnen. Aber das war schon bemerkenswert. Wie dann auch generell, das Spiel wurde unterbrochen. Auch die Atletico-Spieler haben da interveniert und eben die Fans gebeten, so geht es nicht weiter.
Ja, das wollte ich eben fragen, was dann eigentlich die Maßnahmen waren, weil das mit dem Vorwurf habe ich mitbekommen, aber das heißt, es wurde quasi unterbrochen und so.
Genau, da hat das La-Liga-Protokoll dann gegriffen, dass der Schiedsrichter wirklich das Spiel für ein paar Minuten unterbrochen hat. Die Mannschaften blieben auf dem Platz. Stadion-Durchsage natürlich, auch die Atletico-Spieler waren da sehr engagiert, um auf ihr Publikum einzuwirken. Mittlerweile gibt es jetzt Diskussionen, waren das wirklich solche Geräusche oder solche Geräusche, also auch dafür, aber ich meine, der Spieler hat was gehört und hat dann selbst darauf hingewiesen, dass da was gab, von dem her gibt es da für mich nicht viel Spielraum. Der La Liga-Verband hat natürlich dann auch an die verantwortlichen Behörden weitergeleitet. Ich meine, auch eine Person wurde dann schon irgendwie festgenommen, rausgeführt, aber da ist dann auch immer viel Unklares im Raum. Aber so gesehen, diese La Liga-Protokolle-Maßnahmen greifen dann schon und hatten ja auch in den letzten Jahren hier und da schon Übung oder konnten ausgiebig getestet werden, leider.
Und ich würde mal so sagen, wenn du Geräusche von dir gibst, die missverstanden werden könnten als rassistische Beleidigung, dann gibst du vielleicht einfach generell die falschen Geräusche von dir in einem Stadion. Da ist es dann vielleicht auch nicht so wichtig, was es jetzt ganz genau war. Aber gut, das war unser Blick auf die Champions League und auf La Liga und Serie A. In der nächsten Ligatur haben wir dann sicherlich auch wieder die Premier League und vielleicht auch die Ligue 1 mit dabei. Liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, ich hoffe, euch hat die Sendung dennoch gefallen. Mir hat es große Freude gemacht, weil es auch mal schön war, ausführlich über die Champions League zu sprechen und sogar hier im Real Life und dann gespoilert werden vom Spiel. Also ganz herzlichen Dank an euch beiden. Herzlichen Dank an Mario Rieker von Serie Amore natürlich. Und herzlichen Dank an Nils Kern vom Tiki-Taka-Podcast und von Viva La Liga. Danke dir, lieber Nils. Okay, da distanzierst du dich jetzt auf einmal. Oh je, was ist dir da vorgefallen? Ja, Real Total, hast du natürlich recht. Es ist ja sowieso alles verlinkt immer in den Shownotes. Und eigentlich werden es die Hörerinnen und Hörer schon gewusst haben. Also herzlichen Dank an euch beide. Und ich danke natürlich auch Menschen, die diese Sendung möglich gemacht haben. Das sind in diesem Fall Bitzel, MostlyMad, Hannah, Anton, Martin, Georg, Klaas und Daniel T. Sie alle haben uns finanziell unterstützt. Und weil alles hier im Rasenfunk von euch finanziert ist, danken wir an dieser Stelle stellvertretend für euch alle jetzt diesen genannten Personen auf rasenfunk.de/supporterscluberfahrt ihr, wie man uns unterstützen kann. Tut das gerne, empfehlt uns weiter, bleibt gesund und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Macht's gut. Der Rasenfunk lebt von euren Beiträgen. Vielen Dank.